thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask the
speakers to address the meeting
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there'll be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have the
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary in order to clarify any
points that they have made
once a speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
they will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
the chair will open up the meeting for
questions to officers
a debate by the committee and finally
determination on the application by a
vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
finally members this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording of it will
be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you we'll move to the main item
today which is the application for Kayla
Ned forward stroke 21 forward stroke
zero zero nine eight seven four with
stroke o l I will ask the officers to to
do their presentation and in line with
our normal practice I'm going to ask
that the planning officers will tell us
this and that we will have questions
when the presentation is at the end of
this section
is that correct that's right correct
sure thank you
Graham are you
just ask a chair the screen can be
shared so Graham could do the
presentation please
thanks chair thanks Adrian
so this item is an outline application
with all matters other than access
details reserved for up to 36 dwellings
at land off Dart Lane calow
The Proposal is a major development
including 100 affordable housing
biodiversity net gain and financial
contributions
as chair members will be aware a number
of late reps have been received and
they're included in the late
representation pack sent to members
prior to the meeting
and the main issues for this application
they're clearly set out in the officer
reports and the conclusion of officers
is that the benefits of the scheme
including the provision of 100
affordable housing outweighs the
landscape harm in this instance
no statutory consultes have identified
any technical reasons as to why this
application should be refused
so this first slide illustrates the
application site shaded yellow
this game before members today is for up
to 36 dwellings all of which will be
affordable housing as defined in the
local and National planning policy
a single point of access will be
provided in the northern corner of the
application site onto Dart Lane
and you can see the a632 to the north of
the application site
with the application site of butting
Dart Lane
Dart Lane you can see sweeping
around the Eastern Edge and to the south
of the application side
properties on Old School Lane are to the
North and North West of the application
site and you can see the homestead and
individual property which is kind of in
the cut out area to the south of the
site
so this is the red line location plan
submitted with the application you can
see the relationship with properties a
little bit clear on here with those on
Old School Lane to the Northwest and
those on Dart Lanes East
so this is the latest indicative site
plan which confirms the extent of the
developable area put forward by the
applicant
The Proposal before members seeks to
limit the developable area in line with
the current built form of Calo which
would be in line with properties on Old
School Lane and the homestead there to
the South
a large area of open space biodiversity
enhancement and surface water
attenuation is indicated on this plan
excuse me well those details will be
considered at the reserve matter stage
so this next plan illustrates the
proposed access Arrangements into the
site
members will need to be satisfied that
the proposed Works will not have a
severe impact on highway safety and the
surrounding Road Network
they access a new footpath arrangements
are edged in Black so hopefully you can
just make those out
the access and new footpath Arrangements
you can see will connect
just to the north and to the public
right-of-way which kind of backs onto
those properties on Old School Lane
as you can see the plan also illustrates
the required exit visible displays from
dark Lane onto the a632 Chesterfield
Road
and the application site and the road
along Dart Lane will be over width of
5.5 meters
So Yesterday members who attended the
virtual site visit saw a comprehensive
range of photos from around the
application site I've just included a
few photos here just as a reminder of
the sorry of the surrounding area and
what I've done is in the bottom right
hand corner you've just got a map of the
site
and an arrow indicating where the photo
is taken and which direction it's facing
so this first photo taken from the
entrance of the right of way of Dart
Lane
this is also a bridal way and you can
also see South down Dart Lane
so this next photo is taken from a
similar spot adjacent to the right of
way looking back towards the junction
with dark Lane
and Chesterfield Road
so this next view is taken from further
along the right of way looking back into
the application site so you can see the
Homestead Property just in the
background there and the developer area
will be roughly in line with where the
photo is taken back towards the right
edge of the homestead
so this next photo we moved around the
site and it's taken from the public
right-of-way
with the application site on the right
hand side beyond that Hedgerow
so this photo is taken from outside the
application application site excuse me
looking to the South West and it
illustrates The View across the open
Countryside
the proposed amount will be set well
back from this location
so we now move to views from dark Lane
with this photo taken close to the
entrance of the homestead with a list of
Saint Peter's Church in the background
properties on Dart line you can just see
above the Hedgerow on the right hand
side there
so this next photo is again taken from
Dart Lane looking North with the
application site beyond the Hedge on the
left hand side
and these final two slides are taken
from the a632 close to the junction with
dart Lane this is looking East towards
The Pedestrian Crossing you can see the
traffic restrictions the doer lines and
the crossing zigzag so park vehicles are
quite a distance down this stretch of
road
so this final slide is looking West
along the a632 with the list of Saint
Peter's Church on the right hand side
and as you can see there's a there's a
bus stop close to the site and the path
is quite wide in this location
and that concludes my presentation chat
thank you because we have got such a
large amount of speakers after this um
I'm going to ask if there's any points
of clarification members would like to
ask the officers now before we hear the
speakers there will be time for
questions after
Council Armitage
yeah uh could you point out on the map
where the settlement development limit
is where it lies
foreign
[Music]
development boundary I believe kind of
extends along here
and then cuts across
and then follows the sort of
Southwestern Edge
of Dart line and goes behind these
properties
and then goes to the rear of all these
properties on Chesterfield Road
I believe that's correct yep
so it's well outside uh this development
is uh well outside the settlement
development limit
as a statement to the fact yes it is
outside the settlement development
boundaries
other trees going to be checked out
Council Armitage this is just for
clarification questions can come after
you reserve that many questions this is
no sort of marking on if there's a root
protection area on the blunt
right thank you chair
any further points of clarification no
okay we'll bring the first group of
speakers in
foreign
just got a little yellow note here
as we've a large number of speakers on
this application they will require us to
operate in a slightly different way
those wishing to object all are all
currently in the executive meeting room
where they are able to view the meeting
over YouTube
they will then be bought into the
chamber in groups of about five in order
to speak and to answer any questions
when everyone in the group has spoken
and answered any questions they will
then be taken back to the room and the
next group will be brought in
after all those who wish to object have
spoken we will then hear from the agent
who will remain in the chamber
throughout
most of those speakers will do so in
person but a few will do so by Zoom the
list of speakers and the running order
has been circulated to you all as
everyone got a list
thank you
as normal they'll all be informed that
they have their three minutes and then
informed when there's 30 seconds
remaining members will then have the
opportunity to ask any questions they
have
foreign
good afternoon
I believe the first Speaker I have whose
on objection is Jason flaxman
if you'd like to take the table please
you can it won't you'll have three
minutes when you're ready but you cannot
give out anything I'm afraid
no I'm sorry
thank you could you also use your
microphone please Mr flaxman
you might have to angle it up
so three minutes when you're ready
sorry your microphone please if you just
press the button thanks
do I have to press that one okay yeah
okay hang on
can I start again
okay
I'm Jason flaxman I've never cut his
Dart Lane Kayla my family lived in Dart
Lane for 21 years and my property is
directly across the land of the proposed
plan application I'm a resident feels
very stressed and upset at this plan
application and it's caused me numerous
sleepless nights you'll see this
afternoon when I'm not isolated in my
worries and anxieties and following me
will be a lot of residents that feel
exactly the same
after years of planifications on Dart
Lane there's been a gas extraction in
2014 the numerous housing development
plan applications
which is made as a strong resilient
group we're fed up with developers
looking to make money on our beautiful
land
I start my arguments against the
proposed development by speaking about
the proposed plan application being
outside the envelope of the local plan
you can see on my diagram which I can't
hand out but you can see on the diagram
if you look on the website it's outside
the local plan it's my understanding
that this local plan has been approved
by the government and came into effect
on November 2021 and does not change
until 2034.
being outside the local Prime was one of
the many reasons the previous
application was rejected in 2015.
it's also my understanding that has to
be a damn good reason for plan
applications to be approved when they're
outside their local plan there is no
good reasons you will see that this
afternoon 100 affordable hours it is not
a good reason for this to be passed Mark
Fletcher MP for Northeast Derbyshire
also supports our opposition and quotes
I share your concerns for the impact
this will have on Top Road and therefore
written to Northeast Derbyshire District
Council to outline my concerns for the
impact this development will have on the
local road infrastructure Network
it goes on to say it must be done in
consultation with local residents and it
does not have a negative effect on our
beautiful countryside public services
and local community there's been no
consultation with local residents
there's been delays after delays with
constant changes to the development from
the Developers
and then suddenly we get seven days
notice of the planning meeting this is
not what I would call working with the
community
with our public Community we've had
public meetings at the community center
and he's been standing room only in
opposition to this planning permission
you will see from the representations
there's a lot of negative against it and
it's and there's not the necessary
infrastructure it will have a negative
effects
the local MP is against it the parish
council against it and the local
community are against it and they will
certainly not be in the best interest of
the local community thank you
thank you it remain seated are there any
questions for Mr flaxman on the stage
no
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
thank you very much for your time
um next speaker is and I do apologize if
I don't pronounce your surname correctly
is a James Sabio sabido
clear enough yeah never enough three
minutes when you're ready okay I'm Jane
from
on Top Road and the proposed access to
and from the development specifically
the poor visibility of the junction of
Dart Lane onto Top Road and the
increased number of vehicles entering
our leaving Dart Lane onto Top Road
Chesterfield Road which leads into Top
Road in Kayla the a632 is a very busy
main road from Chesterfield it is also
the main route to the hospital from
Chesterfield and the M1 constantly and
it carries constantly carries emergency
vehicles to the hospital Top Road has
parked cars parked all the way down it
has Terrace housing buttoned up to it
and a narrow footpath for pedestrians
those earlier photos aren't
representative of what Top Road is today
this proposed development will clearly
add traffic to Top Road and this is in
addition to the three already planned
unapproved developments but not yet
built which was free Vehicles onto Top
Road as well as the recent transverse
gate development already built this now
equates to around 400 extra cars
carrying Vehicles onto a small stretch
of Main Road this proposed development
application has failed to take into
account the severity of the severe
severely restricted visibility from the
line of parked cars outside the
properties on Top Road when trying to
pull out of Dart Lane we within a meter
of this Junction there is also a
pedestrian Crossing as you saw in the
photos two bus stops one with no pulling
and a further Junction almost opposite
again impeding invisibility and creating
further safety concerns on a very busy
main road if traffic were added as
highways commented in their original
electron 15th of September 2021 the
proposed development traffic on Dart
Lane would struggle to seek gaps to to
turn right to and from Dart Lane and may
result in potential safety issue and if
they're referring to development traffic
then surely traffic from additional
residents will also result in potential
safety issues and I cannot see how this
can be changed the additional vehicles
from this properties development will
only serve to exacerbate this issue the
impact of traffic from all these
developments combined is unacceptable
and the parish council with highways
agree with highways original comments
that the proposed development of uh on
Dart Lane may result in a potential
safety issue already at Peak capacity
adding more Vehicles is completely
unreasonable I've not even mentioned the
impact of delivery vehicles from new the
new households and worse is to come when
Crow Lane closes further 30 seconds
remaining Road in summary given the
additional uh given the recent housing
developments in Kayla the extra cars
joining the saturated stretch of road is
totally unacceptable and proposing to
add even more is completely Bonkers add
to this the critical ambulance traffic
where every second cows and there is the
potential for a regular daily disaster
everyone knows this road is all have
already heavily congested have any of
you tried to travel down at peak times
when an ambulance is trying to get
through that's time chair approving the
development thank you this is crazy
thank you thank you any questions if
you'd like to remain suited just in case
there are
you would try to make a quick getaway
there
oh and you can now
our next speaker Ian ulcock
three minutes when you're ready okay my
name is Ian holcock I live on the great
at greenbriars.lane
they're currently 43 homes on dark Lane
and that doesn't include the Traveler's
side it's all extremely difficult for
residents of Dart Lane to park their
vehicles anywhere near their home and
the situation is already exacerbated by
uh by the number of residents from top
row using Dart Lane as their car park
hospital employees using it dartling as
a car park and also people using the
Calo church as a car park
therefore the propelled development of
36 houses would nearly double the number
of houses on dark Lane which would
therefore nearly double the current
traffic issues Northeast Derbyshire
Council already in 2015 rejected uh
building of house on Dart Lane and one
of the reasons giving was because of
traffic
and it could be argued that that's those
arguments are still the same there's no
nothing has changed except
that post-covered traffic has increased
because more people are building online
shopping so the preparation of delivery
vehicles also added to that in the in
2022 the highway code placed a more
responsibility on drivers of larger of
larger cars and larger vehicles uh and
give them more responsibility so that
could also cause greater congestion as
previously mentioned at the top of Dart
Lane there's a popular shop called Halo
carbs access to and from dark Lane onto
Top Road is often restricted by delivery
vehicles making deliveries two kilo
clubs and customer cars taking up very
often the width of the of the uh of the
lane down to my home which is
greenbriars which is just about the
proposed entry exit points for this
Housing Development
so switch parking makes exiting the top
Road of Dart Lane onto Top Road very
difficult especially during school term
time and I understand that whilst number
of traffic servers have been doing it's
my understanding that they've been doing
in in school holidays maybe maybe we've
got this less traffic on school all the
time
Darlings also used as a Rat Run uh
coming up from the from the area of
Caleb Green we sell vehicles will bypass
Bowl Hill that increases traffic
congestion both at the bottom of Dart
Lane and also the top of Dart Lane
it's further compounded I'm traffic
certainly on a Wednesdays when the
Refuge collection vehicle charged to
access
oh that'll pour down and that that's and
those problems cannot be understated
speeding is an also addition there's
also a problem on Dart Lane especially
from the air from the homestead to the
top of dartley and Kayla carbs at least
one car at least one car's been
completely written off and other cars
have in fact been damaged because people
are using it as a bit of a race track
I'll therefore urge this committee yet
again to reject this planet this
planning application
thank you
thank you are there any questions
hello if you'd like to take a seat
our next speaker is Claire flexman
again in three minutes when you're ready
yeah afternoon thank you everybody
my name is Claire flaxman my family have
lived on Dart Lane directly opposite
this land for 21 years I'm angry upset
and I've had sleepless nights caused by
the inaccuracies of what effect this
development would have on Dart Lane
I'm not an expert on planning just an
anxious mom who's wanting to stop this
and protect Dart Lanes though future
residents can enjoy and love it as much
as we do
my reasons for refusal are one increase
of traffic the access and entrance is
situated on the most dangerous Junction
on Dart Lane I live there so I know
the plans totally dismiss and
underestimate reality
two relationships amongst residents the
development would create a poor
relationship with existing residents
parking and traffic issues being the
main reasons
three it's not called Dart Lane for
nothing it's dark dark Lane is dark we
like it dark we have old-fashioned dimly
lit Street lighting creating a peaceful
scene highly lit housing estate will
create bright light shining directly
into our properties and windows
I want to take this opportunity to
remind you that in 2015 Northeast
Derbyshire refused a similar planning
application on this exact piece of land
I spoke at that meeting and I believe
the council's reasons for refusal still
apply today
the council's three reasons were one the
site is located outside the settlement
development limit for Calo the loss of
Greenfield would have a detrimental
impact on the character of the area and
there's an area of open Countryside it's
lost it's not outweighed by the social
and economic benefits as per the local
plan
two the development would access onto
Dart Lane where on-road parking is
prevalent and off-road parking Limited
access to the main Highway network is
already restricted and the additional
traffic generated would have a
detrimental impact on the existing
Highway Network as Dart Lane is too
narrow to accommodate additional traffic
access from the site to Dart Lane both
north and south top Road and Calo Lane
would have an adverse impact on highway
safety the cumulative impact from the
development is severe contrary to the
National planning policy and local plan
surgeries and the application is
considered unacceptable
dark the development would introduce
straighten of the lighting that would
adversely affect the local landscape
contrary to National policy framework
for a planning application to succeed it
should be demonstrated that the proposed
development should improve an area and
the lives of those nearby this does
neither more accurately it does the
exact opposite the negative points
totally outweigh any reason for yet
another house in state in Calo please
refuse these plans and put the views of
this community at the heart of your
decision thank you thank you are there
any questions
we're doing well today thank you thank
you
our next speaker is Stuart Ellis
three minutes when you're ready
thank you chair uh Stuart Ellis from
Chesterfield Royal Hospital uh
this development would absolutely uh
further add to the significant and
growing burden on the hospital of
development in Northeast Derbyshire and
more widely in Derbyshire this case is
sort of a watershed moment for us as
your provider of Hospital health care to
find a sustainable Way Forward as a
partner in Derbyshire we've worked
tirelessly in an effort to support
joined up public work in the last three
years and consistently meet a glass
ceiling of willingness to apply National
provisions of section 106 uh planning
stage and inconsistent information
requests across all authorities
the requirement for section 106 was
documented To Us by playing officers in
September as meeting the three tests for
this development and accepted by the
director of Stan cliff subsequently once
the number of houses was slightly
reduced on the application and the
overall funding envelope of
contributions reduced it's now deemed to
not meet the tests or to be required
ignoring the clear health impact instead
of a reduced contribution for all if
this was what was needed
we've provided probably the most robust
evidence time after time in multiple
formats as to the impact and can
evidence both capital and non-capital
impacts every development has on the
hospital
in responding to increased growth rate
and demand in the area in recent years
the new emergency care centers had to be
expanded from its original intentions
seven years ago at a cost of almost six
million this year over and above the
national contributions our MRI scanner
at 1.7 had to be replaced early taking
account of demand and the speed of
equipment amongst other things and these
are just examples where development is
putting pressure onto patient care
consequence of this are delays and
replacing other equipment whether it be
a gamma camera or ventilator monitoring
systems that have to be delayed one two
or even three years just as working
examples of unsupported development
impacts
the local plan which refers to Primary
Care only is frequently and misleadingly
presented
um as a reason to exclude one of the
most costly and critical parts of
infrastructure along with schools and
social care from 106 support this is
misleading the local planning process
failed to understand that Derbyshire ccg
only act on behalf of gp's dentists and
pharmacies and completely failed to
consult with it as a major stakeholder
in setting the plan this doesn't change
the legislation provision of 106. we
completely understand the challenge
planning officers face between
delivering housing targets and meeting
Council pressures but they're also The
Gatekeepers for the whole system on 106
not just the councils and this seems to
be getting lost to the detriment to the
hospital and therefore
and there for us that this application
is rejected as it stands as it will
directly impact on the hospital and
we've repeatedly evidence that it meets
the three tests in the application we've
made and our data model is currently
being used successfully now that we
helped develop between Nottingham
Coventry and Warwickshire
um possibly a matter for another day to
discuss with members or that's the base
of our objection
thank you any questions
no thank you very much
you'll now file back to the other room
where you can watch proceedings and the
next group will be coming in
thank you
um
thank you
thank you
foreign
okay
it's so easy
people
apparently you are all here
uh the first speaker is Mr Wells Chris
Wells
Mr Wells I believe you're also going to
be speaking on with regards for your
wife so I'm going to allow you to speak
first answer any questions and then
speak again for your wife okay thank you
just so my colleagues know that I
haven't totally flipped
that's three minutes when you're ready
uh right I'm Chris Wells uh I live on
Top Road sorry darling
um air pollution so road is a bottleneck
it has become a natural traffic cue and
this and the stationary traffic
generator
this traffic jam this traffic congestion
is a major source of air pollution in Ko
the minor sources of air pollution occur
when Motor Vehicles are waiting or
queuing at the side road Junctions on
top row Oaks Farm Lane this will become
more
polluted with the introduction of the
new Oaks Farm estate Lawn Village
when cars are parked outside the mini
Supermarket there'll be delays and
difficulty getting out
the exit from the new housing estate
behind the Old Post Office
that will cause air pollution
and the exit from the school old school
escape estate onto top row causes minor
air pollution
the major could you turn that fan off
please
it's affecting my hearing
is it sorry
sorry
the the major sources of air pollution
occur when Motor Vehicles are waiting or
or queuing for long periods of time at
the following Side Road Junctions on Top
Road and Top Road itself the mini around
about blinking Blacksmith Lane
irregularly Motor Vehicles on Top Road
restrict the flow of traffic on Top Road
it is not possible for two or more large
vehicles to pass in opposite direction
because of the park Vehicles so one
stream of traffic has to give way to
oncommer traffic so it comes a race to
reach gaps between
the rate of traffic through Halo
increasing air pollution
the entrance and exit of both the co-op
and hospital car park there will be an
accident in this area soon there is
chaos at times with cars wanting to
enter and exit both car parks at the
same time and queues are building above
directions on top row there's also
problems on Dart Lane
Church Lane and The Pedestrian Crossing
these sources of Motor Vehicle air
pollution are pretty cumulative to such
an extent that an air quality survey was
carried out at the junction of Dart Lane
and Top Road by Imperial College London
on behalf of the World Health Authority
the results of this survey place this
Junction in the 51st 30 seconds
remaining 51st National percentile Amber
region which can lead to the following
medical conditions wheezing bronchitis
dementia and calo
can you pull with and they have to
bridge you improve and air quality this
pollution has probably contributed to my
wife's lung cancer
thank you
thank you are there any questions at
this point
you've remain seated and now you've got
another three minutes are you is that it
can I can I just point out one mistake
in in Graham's presentation
you may
um there is a photograph of uh Kayla
Cubs
uh at the junction of top Road
and dark Lane
on that Junction it shows two yellow
lines
those are not official yellow lines
there is no blue notice
it says that there are there is a
parking restriction so technically those
yellow lines are just a cosmetic uh to
try and stop people from parking
on the corner okay thank you okay thank
you very much
are you wanting to speak now on behalf
of your wife or just your presentation
cover it all no I can I get another one
for my wife
just give me a chance to get it out
just take your time do you have to do
this all the time yes
um
okay drainage and rainwater runoff and
tarantula Wayne which is more common in
the future due to global warming this
housing estate has the perfect design to
direct the flow of water runoff downhill
towards the brook Bowl Hill which will
flood little attempt has been made in
this planning application to control
water runoff or for the land to absorb
the excess water and consequently houses
close to the brook at Bow Hill would be
flooded
the book at bowel Hill would be flooded
when heavy water falls on one top Road
um it just heads straight down it's
because because of them before
um whenever he whenever whenever heavy
rainfalls on the fields obviously it's
on our home we're home where it is
planned to build 36 dwellings
it's naturally flows towards the corner
near 13 netherley Cottages it all was
there it also floods the road
um
this proposed estate is designed in such
a way as to direct the flow of water to
run off this field down the side to the
road
towards the road that way between the
corner of 13 other across on each
cottages and the corner by the homestead
the effects of this rainwater runoff
will be worse there will be greater flow
of water which will flood the road and
flow through the homestead land the rain
water Runner will then flow down to Burl
Hill
it needs to be pointed out that there is
a large water main flowing diagonally
across the field adjacent to Donald Lane
and that this water main would need to
be repositioned this the field opposite
uh
my hole on Dart Lane is also
contaminated with organophosphates in
the 1970s father the farmer said Smith
organized compulsory twice a yearly
sheep's opinion for his sheep sheep in
this field and
she gives itself was made available for
other local farmers to dip their sheep
any disturbance of this land through
building will come and contaminate
Norland this planning application will
not provides with the proposed drainage
Manchester mandatory for new development
2024.
it must have suspense to sustainable
drainage 30 seconds remaining it must
have sustainable drainage as grass areas
permanent permeable services and
wetlands to put to curb the flooding of
pollution incorporate sustainable
Drainage Systems to reduce risk of
surface Wars are flooding and relieve
pressure on traditional sewerage systems
which can get over overwhelmed by heavy
rain
in other words it's gonna flow
thank you are there any questions thank
you
no if you'd like to take a seat thank
you very much thank you
I believe we have a Mr Carl winter is
joining us by Zoom
there he goes hello he's back hello
thank you
three minutes when you're ready Mr
winter
thank you my main concern is regarding
the degradation to our Amino cleat of
the Emergency Services as you know we're
a small community living on a single
track Lane with passing places
the residents of this Lane have a very
varied age range and regularly requires
visits from the NHS in particular
this normally arrives in the form of an
ambulance which is very often dispatched
from the hospital
bearing in mind the response times for a
category one or two call are 7 and 18
minutes respectively
as the center of the lane is less than a
mile from the hospital the journey at
present is approximately five minutes
meaning even a category one response is
likely to be served within an NHS
guideline this greatly helps in creating
a more satisfactory outcome to any
emergency as the patient will arrive in
hospital inside the Golden House
we as a community only have two access
points to our residences
and are very concerned about the
degradation of this amenity
with the extra volume of vehicles used
in the already restricted entries to
Dart Lane up top Road
the likelihood of an ambulance having a
clear passage to any of our community
will greatly be affected
Vehicles can't simply move out of the
way as is normally the case due to the
nature of the junction and the fact that
it is a single track Lane
should the ambulance up to reroute due
to this congestion
then any diversion would have abs sorry
any diversion would add an absolute
minimum of two miles and five minutes to
the response this delay would also be on
both ambulance Journeys and will be
greatly affect any of our residents
chances of being treated within the
golden hour and ultimately their chances
of recovery from a serious accident or
illness
all of these facts are based on one uh
sorry all of these facts are based on
once the premises are in place if it is
accepted but during the build phase the
damage to this amenity will be
significantly greater due to the extra
volume of vehicles both parking in the
area and delivering Goods struck
Services needed to supply the
contractors we would greatly appreciate
your consideration of these facts and
the degradation it causes to the
emergency service amenity provided to
our small community thank you
thank you are there any questions
thank you very much Mr winter
thank you
and we have another speaker Liz vardy
three minutes when you're ready
okay I have lived on Dart Lane for 30
years opposite the proposed site Dart
Lane is a quiet peaceful semi-rural
mostly single track Lane quite unique in
style and character to introduce a
housing estate into this environment
would fundamentally and adversely change
the character of it it is an area that
is valued and enjoyed by local residents
for its character and quiet Lane status
the field proposed for development is an
historic Greenfield site set in open
Countryside the fields of majestic trees
add to the local environment this part
of Kayla is treasured by local residents
who enjoy the rural setting which is
within walking distance of everyone in
Calo it offers local people local access
to quiet Countryside these Open Fields
and Views support good mental health and
well-being which has been even more
important during the pandemic and
continued recording from it we have seen
a significant increase in people walking
down Dart Lane and around the fields
during and since the lockdowns some have
even commented talk to those of us that
live on the lane that they never realize
such a beautiful part of Kayla existed
being a quiet Lane allows local folk to
safely enjoy their Hobbies such as
cycling walking horse riding and dog
walking also important for everyone's
well-being mental health and fitness
these non-powered Road users including
pedestrians now have priority status
over Vehicles who by law have to give
them one and a half meter passing
clearance
principal increasing traffic there are
getting fewer and fewer safe places for
horse riders in Calo and this is one
area that remains a place they can enjoy
a new safely bringing more traffic onto
the lane will compromise this and put
horses and riders in danger Northeast
Derbyshire District Council encourage
healthy lifestyle choices so has a
responsibility to make sure Aries remain
safe
this rural part of Kayla must be
retained to preserve the character of
this Village which is managing to keep
its Village identity and individuality
in an Ever increasingly urbanized area
it should and must be protected for
future Generations just because a green
field exists does not mean the only
value it has or use for it is to build
on it it is an asset to the village and
environment just by being there
particularly in the current Global and
climate crisis so in summary there would
be an unacceptable loss of Quiet Lane
status unacceptable adverse impact on
the amenities of the properties
immediately bordering the site and the
surrounding areas by reason of
overlooking loss of privacy light
pollution noise pollution and Visually
overbearing impact the proposal by
reasonability seconds Remain the
proposal by reason of its sighting would
lead to a fragmented of development
being out of keeping with and
detrimental to the character and
appearance of the area and would be
harmful to the open Rural and
undeveloped character of this site and
quiet Lane status for these reasons I
ask you to refuse this application
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no if you'd like to take a seat thank
you
and the last speaker for this group is
Joe Hancock
three minutes when you're ready thank
you this is neddc local plan
2014-34 the sustainability appraisal
appendix a only shows two areas for
development in Calo Church Meadows on 20
houses Off Top Road presumably the fold
the map clearly shows this and out
claims sites as outside the settlement
limits developments allowed next to
boundaries must be appropriate if they
are to be built at all my MP Mark
Fletcher and councilor Jack Willey are
unavailable but I've granted me
permission to mention their letters Mark
campaigns for affordable housing but
States clearly it must be done in
consultation with local residents and
not have the severe impact on their
lives Community or landscape which this
would undoubtedly would councilor woolly
commenced that none of these new
developments Kayla get it right when it
comes to highways and they both share
our concerns today which were are the
same reasons for its refusal in 2015.
availability Assessments in 2016
allocated 73 new properties in Calo a
level two cvflct settlement moment
according to the hierarchy which is more
than provided for by Woodall Homes at
Travis gate 30 Church Meadows 45 and
Oaks Lane 79. this site offers 100
affordable homes not on open market for
key workers needlessly above the 20 to
30 required a percentage have already
been removed from the other developments
in Calo and I worry this will follow
suit and this plan is an attempt to get
a previously declined proposal approved
on a site that is is is not suitable I
doubt they will remain affordable
forever as it seems to be the trend
affordable houses are generally cheaply
built and out of character key workers
have a higher incidence of shift work
and at this concentration resulting in
high numbers of vehicle movements in the
night as they go on and off shift
disturbing all the residents Ned housing
strategy 2021-24 States everyone has a
right to live in a decent home with
surroundings to be proud of a place
where people feel safe happy and healthy
to protect the most vulnerable and this
should apply to existing residents not
to just people with a knee need Dart
Lane is a unique gem in a busy 24 7
Society semi-rawal where residents enjoy
Peace Quiet Countryside and darkness to
truly relax after work go for Pleasant
Country Walk or horse ride horse houses
rarely come up for sale here as
residents like it the way it is this
development would drastically change
this Outlook by a hundred percent at
netherley the local plan was formulated
to ensure residents have sufficient
Access to Health Facilities which help
present our stretch to capacity and that
major crisis Point sustainability is the
inward yet
houses will be eco-friendly despite
local transport links people will still
use cars and turn right down dark Lane
to avoid queues on Top Road which is a
single track Lane with one passing place
the nearest Secondary School in hustling
means travel by the red already
congested Kayla Lane just field us in a
huge increase in housing in the past two
years alone and with more big
developments in the pipeline surely
enough is enough until local
infrastructure can support more thank
you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much can I just point
out that we as a group sorry you've had
your three minutes but this is different
there's only a reason today and it's
about
um the speaking for three minutes we
were informed that we could only speak
for three minutes which included
speaking for somebody else
that's why Mr Wells had his time he had
two two
we were told that we could only have
three minutes to include ours and
somebody else's that's what we were told
and my partner will back me up on that
because that's what we were told I'm
sorry if there's been any confusion on
that uh what exactly if you'd just leave
the details or email me afterwards we'll
check up on that yeah thank you
thank you and if you'd like to go back
to your other little room
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
for a member to rejoin us we're trying
to Abate some of the noise issues that
we've been suffering from
okay
um our first Speaker from this group is
Annie wood he'd like to take the little
C
have three minutes when you're ready
we're living in a time now where you
cannot Escape conversations about our
planet and its future my family myself
are not alone in being overwhelmed with
Stress and Anxiety on a daily basis
thinking about what our world will look
like in time to come because it's clear
from our daily news that on every level
not enough is being done part of our
climate emergency is not just about
reducing carbon emissions but increasing
biodiversity and improving and
protecting the environmental aspects of
the communities in which we live we need
green spaces for both physical and
mental well-being and for the health of
our planet this much is clear because
the nedc has recognized it and it's now
written into their climate strategy and
their planning as part of the nadc's
climate strategy the council's 2019-23
vision is a district that is attractive
where people are proud to live and work
where they will prosper and be safe
happy and healthy get the approval of
this planning application will mean that
this won't be the case as it will mean
yet another loss of a Greenfield site in
our village wherever this application is
in direct conflict with any DC's
directive of effective planning and
management of our green infrastructure
to provide access to Quality green
spaces within our communities part of
one of the wonderful things about Calo
being what should be and should remain a
semi-rural village are what remaining
green spaces we have as they are an
amenity for all the residents many
councils are now adopting green and Open
Spaces strategies which underscores how
important it is to make a stand when it
comes to preventing building on
Greenfield spaces wherever possible the
preservation of the land on Dart Lane
will contribute to biodiversity in fact
there can be no higher net gain for
biodiversity than this protection
enables a sustainable landscape and also
makes a contribution to reducing the
impact of climate change and help us
work towards our climate change targets
finally it's part of the nadc's
commitment to enable people to better
manage their Quality of Life Health and
well-being and Empower communities to
drive sustainable change ultimately our
community does not agree with the
proposed planning application and so in
line with any DC's directives we must be
listened to this Greenfield site
deserves our protection and we need to
consider people and the planet and the
future thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you you'd like to take your
seat our next speaker Owen down right
Downey
three minutes when you're ready
um the stretch of dark Lane immediately
facing the development site comprises
four houses with off-street parking and
13 houses with no off street parking
assuming five meters per vehicle the
street parking per street parking space
then one calf each of the 13 houses
requires 65 meters of space two cars per
house requires 130 meters however that
section of Dart Lane only provides about
120 meters of street parking then
Factory in parking by Top Road residence
visitors and other parking for people
using the allotments corner shop Etc
it's clear there's all the insufficient
parking space on Dart Lane all our local
councilors MP and Parish Council raised
the issue of traffic and parking their
objections sometimes it is people with
local knowledge who have a better idea
of the real world implications of
inappropriate development rather than
non-local remote based consultancies
that are commissioned by the developer
following a site visit the committee
gave the following is a reason for
refusal of the previous virtually
identical development the development
would access onto Dart Lane where
on-road parking is prevalent and
off-road parking limited access to the
main Highway network is already
restricted the additional traffic
from the development would have a
detrimental impact on the existing
Highway Network and start then it's too
narrow to accommodate the additional
traffic and the access from the sign
Dart Lane to the North and South
respectively would have an adverse
impact on Highway Safety in its swept
path analysis for vehicles entering and
exiting the new development the
transport statement does not account for
part vehicles on darling DC hope CC
highways do realize this in their
response and say that traffic regulation
orders are necessary to avoid
obstructions from parked cars I.E
parking restrictions on Dart Lane will
be implemented
so we end up in the ludicrous situation
that existing residents who have no off
street parking will have their street
parking removed in order to allow the
new housing to be built and this new
housing will be provided with off-sheet
parking as a base requirement I cannot
see what justification there is for this
In fairness and how it will not have a
serious adverse effect on the existing
residents in fact the TS makes no
mention at all of the existing car
parking on Dart Lane which effectively
makes it single track for its entire
length so this must surely introduce
inaccuracy into the various traffic
predictions and calculations made in the
report
similarly those little mention of
accidents the TS acknowledges two
incidents in recent years but as
residents we are aware of many more of
course many near misses in my own family
my daughter's car was hit and written
off by a passing car while it was parked
on Dart Lane at the point of the new
entrance to the development police
incidence insurance claims were made
last year my son's girlfriend was
involved in a collision at the junction
of dartley in the top Road also an
insurance claim either of these could
have resulted in serious injury or worse
if this development is permitted it's
only a matter of time
the committee had the foresight to
recognize the importance of these issues
in refusing the previous application
nothing has changed with this latest
proposal
the new Junction is in the same place
and there are now more houses proposed
proposed therefore the same concerns
previously cited by the committee remain
valid for this application it should be
similarly refused essentially this
proposal is a square peg in a round hole
thank you
thank you are there any questions
counselor Hall if you'd like to remain
sorry I'd like to ask you a question
please yeah you touched upon the reasons
for refusal in 2015 uh citing traffic
congestion parking Etc would you say
then over the last seven years that
traffic has stayed roughly the same
including parking
decreased or increased and if it's
increased would you say substantialized
oh no yeah well it's hard to tell
because there was a dip during the
covert period
um but certainly in the last year as
traffic flows are coming back up I think
it was also uh increased use of the
allotments which again that that sort of
increased during
uh lockdown period so there's a lot more
parking for people using the allotments
at the back
um so I mean and yeah I'm noticing it
it's increasing it is that there's been
a notice increase in the last year
um
thank you another point on that though I
would say in the transport stage it does
it assume that Vehicles would go 24
miles an hour along that stretch which
we know they don't we see them go past
and clearly the one that wrote off my
daughter's car is going a lot faster
um so they do travel on that stretch at
high speed
okay thank you
thank you
our next speaker is Karen Haywood
three minutes when you're ready
thank you I'm Karen haywards of Milltown
ashover representing the British horse
Society on behalf of local Riders
with six
years
although I think it's working again
if you'd like to start a game about from
the beginning
I'm currently world of Milton ashover
representing the British horse Society
on before half of local riders with 696
horses registered postcodes at Sheffield
4-4 the annual revenue is worth over 3.8
8 million to the local economy there are
over 22 equestrian properties within a
one mile radius of dark Lane Calo
including Bloomington Equestrian Center
several commercial Library hours plus
many private horse owners the off-road
provision for questions is extremely
fragmented with only 11 in Derbyshire
nationally the figure is 22 the main
off-road route in the area is the
transper 9 Trail Greenway a national
cycle network but access access to it is
often along busy roads Dart Lane and
Kayla bridalway Aid is an important link
to the transplant on trail for over 12
equestrian properties south of the a632
with approximately 25 Riders regularly
using these routes to then cross his
busy road onto Church Lane and after
riding for another half a mile
eventually accessed the TPT however this
access is compromised at the present
time by one no Road signage on a632
showing horse crossing point to poor
sight lines in the dark Lane Junction
three congested and curing traffic both
on a632 a narrow Junction of Dart Lane
four Riders cannot operate the Pelican
Crossing and often wait for pedestrians
or cyclists to activate the lights five
they're often parked Vehicles customers
at the local shop blocking the entrance
to the poorly sign right away all of
these problems are only set to be
exacerbated if the proposed development
is passed the new abscess point is only
20 meters away from the bridalway access
where sight lines for both emerging
vehicles under questions unlimited and
these hazards are set to increase during
the construction phase with hgvs and
other large Vehicles accessing the site
regularly
in mitigation one increased signage on
the a632 horse Crossing on the bridal
way do not obstruct the ride away two
make Dart Lane A Quiet Lane with the 20
mile per hour speed limit and signs
showing pedestrian cyclist Riders having
priority over motorized traffic in
accordance with the new highway code
legislation
sign the passing places to prevent
parking three upgrade the Pelican
Crossing to a pegasus with new lights
operable from the dart Lane Junction
for look to increase the greenway
Network by the upgrade of suitable for
30 seconds remaining to right away
status or creation of new
policies National policy planning
framework paragraph 100 Northeast
Derbyshire local plan id8 and wcfi the
British Hall society would be pleased to
be involved in this process thank you
thank you are there any questions
know if you'd like to take a seat
our next speaker is glennis McLaughlin
three minutes when you're ready
my name is Dennis McLaughlin like many
of the residents on Dart Lane I chose to
reside here over 25 years ago due to the
rural character appearance and
Tranquility of Dart Lane the scientists
adjacent to footpaths and Bridal away
increased daily use was evident during
covid and has continued I fear this will
decline due to the noise emitted by the
development side the planning
application has been amended several
times obviously the developer and
Northeast are desperate for this to be
granted even though an unprecedented
number of residents have objected
noise from the initial construction
heavy God's vehicle plant machinery
in and out of the site together with
building work will be a constant daily
disturbance from 36 dwellings everyday
living noises such as vehicle noise
possible 72 movements in and out of the
housing estate standing vehicles at the
T Junction Garden Machinery fireworks
dogs barking noisy children playing all
of which are alien to the peaceful Dart
Lane area and will be stressful for
existing residence noise can have a
significant effect on health and quality
of life causing Stress and Anxiety
especially for shift workers noise can
adversely affect wildlife and ecosystems
noise from the site during the whole
process will be heard further down Dart
Lane affecting even more residents
reducing the number of dwellings to 36
by not using Fields two and three but to
increase the green space and provide a
pond will encourage young people to
congregate there as there is no
facilities within Klo for young people
to meet up
this has the potential to cause
anti-social Behavior drinking littering
football loud music The Green Space is
isolated and the pond is a safety issue
there are several equestrian yards
nearby who graze their horses in close
proximity to the site the site is
adjacent to a main Bridal way and
presents a major Hazard to Riders and
their horse being flight animals and
sudden noises can spoke them causing
them to bolt which could result in
serious injury to horse and or Rider I
understand the need for housing but
Kayla has been subjected to many new
developments over the last few years
all on Farmland despite commentaries by
the community the site is obviously a
bone of contention and cannot be 30
seconds remain cannot be suitable or
sustainable for development the
residents of Calo will be losing their
valued Green Space and soundscape which
currently benefits the whole Community
instead subjected to unnecessary noise
and upheaval from this development I
strongly as a planning committee to
listen to What the residents are saying
and why they do not approve of this
development
and to vote to reject this application
for the harm it will cause
thank you are there any questions
no no if you'd like to take your seat
and next speaker is here Ian Willetts
three minutes when you're ready
thank you
my partner and I live in probably the
oldest house in Calo built in 1554 and
presently well currently and always will
be on dark Lane I wish to raise the
subject of the Lost immunity in the form
of the relative darkness of our lane
which results in a wonderful clear skies
and for stargazing and our watching I
fail to understand how development of
some 36 houses can be considered on dark
Lane the extra light generated by 36
properties and the resultant light
pollution must be in direct conservation
of your own planning rules especially is
it to the outside the approved
Development Area when we applied to
Northeast Derbyshire planning department
for our Menage under application
1900029 FL it was passed with conditions
specifically condition four which has no
which was that no X external lighting
shall be provided this was clarified in
the section reason for conditions it
clearly states to provide obtrusive to
prevent obtrusive light causing a loss
of immunity to neighboring dwellings in
accordance with policies gs6 and R9 of
the Northeast Derbyshire local plan and
policy gs9 of the publication draft
local plan
2014-2034 this has now been formally
accepted on the 29th of November 2021
personally I fail to understand how we
were not allowed any external lights on
a menage that is only visible from the
second floor of our property behind a
12-foot hedge and not in view of any
neighboring properties due to obtrusive
light causing a loss of immunity to
neighboring dwellings however somehow
now 36 new modern properties their
Associated vehicle movements and all the
required Street lighting do not cause
obtrusive light causing a loss of
immunity to neighboring dwellings
especially since within 10 meters and
directly opposite this development there
are 20 existing properties that will be
direct definitely have this amenity
adversely affected and only have a small
Hedgerow to try and Screen them this is
also only allowed to grow to two main
this will be even worse for the owners
of the homestead who will be completely
surrounded by this development and its
subsequent light pollution I will be
very grateful if you could please
consider the obtrusive light causing a
loss of immunity to neighboring
dwellings as a reason to decline this
development this is not only a loss of
immunity for the residents of Dart Lane
and Caleb but also all of the residents
of Ball Hill Bloomington in the
houseland that make use of that time
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much if you'd like to
take a seat may I also say it was my
partner that said that we've been told
we could only comment on one subject
even if people had
asked for stuff to be I spoke to Graham
on the phone and said that there was a
neighbor that wanted something reading
out but was told that I would have to do
it in the same three minutes as this so
can I at least leave it for people to
read or be considered for a second three
minutes
thank you
if you actually it has a slight
consultation here if you'd like to read
the letter
but again it would be subject to the
same three-minute rule yes sir thank you
dark Lane has an existing Bridal way
which joins it within a few meters of
Top Lane
Taylor Bridal way number eight is
frequently used to root with for many
horse riders the demarcation point of
this Bridal way is already very
difficult to negotiate there are seven
reasons for this
no Road signage for of the joining
Bridal way close proximity to Top Road
Junction
queuing traffic associated with top row
Junction congested traffic trying to
enter dark Lane parked vehicles on the
bridal way all of these hazards will be
greatly increased by the provision of
the development's only access point
which will be within 20 meters of the
bridalway access the issues associated
with the proximity of this new
development Junction will also be
massively enhanced by the fact that it
will be a blind Junction for Riders
leaving the bridal way this is because a
rider will need to keep their horse a
meter or two back from the junction
meaning the rider will be approximately
four meters back from the road due to
the existing vegetation and hedge line
neither the horse rider leaving the
bridal way nor the driver leading the
development will be able to see the
househood
in my opinion this will create an
unacceptably dangerous Junction
involving three access points within 30
to 40 meters each other
the in light of the unacceptably
increased risk to life presented by any
change to this complex Junction I
believe the development should be
declined if not it should be half
considered sorry if not it should have
certain conditions imposed to hence
enhance the safety of all Road users
whether that be Rider horse or vehicle
driver if this development is passed
maybe the council or development should
mitigate the risk to life of the
junction
will impose by putting new signage up
warning all users of the danger The
Junction presents along with yellow
lines and hatchings painted on the
bridalway access point to prevent
dangers associated with the junction
being increased even further by illegal
parking of the bridal way thank you very
much I appreciate that thank you if
you'd like to take a seat sorry chair
just before you go could we have your
neighbor's name please
yes it's ishvan I can't I can't say I
can't pronounce his surname
uh I have to look at it
it's a it's a Hungarian name can I give
it a year let me give it in a minute uh
yes you certainly yeah it's consulowski
or something I'll have to look it up
sorry
okay thank you if you'd like to go back
to the waiting room
right
um
that's okay
if you just email it later on
thank you very much
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
I believe our first speaker for this
group is Rebecca Crowley
three minutes when you're ready just
hang on one second
slight change to running order
so
that one's on
okay
three minutes when you're ready sorry
about that
I replied to the proposed development on
the grounds that this is detrimental to
the mental health of the residents of
darkline Calo and surrounding areas for
the reasons I will outline
so this prove that when stress becomes
overwhelming and prolonged the risks to
mental health problems and medical
problems increase and can cause
development of mental health issues
mental health is currently the biggest
burden on the NHS with studies showing
one in four people will suffer a mental
health issue each year and it costs the
UK economy 118 billion pounds a year
depression has increased 17 in the last
three years and strong correlations can
be found between mental health issues
and population density
as you can see from these facts mental
health is already a significant problem
across the UK
the proposed development on dark Lane
has had a considerable impact on the
mental health of the residents of dark
Lane and surrounding areas myself
included
the amount of stress that has been
inflicted through this has been immense
and when you add in the concerns of
relational factors such as destruction
of local wildlife and environment the
potential loss of the open space the
constant planning Associated letters
arriving it's endless it's anxiety
inducing
many of the residents on dark Lane moved
there because of the peace and quiet and
the nature that surrounds the houses and
dark Lanes it benefits their mental
health they wanted a quieter life
some people like myself have lived in
places with a higher population density
and suffers stress as consequences of
that
immersing yourself in nature has proven
advantages to mental well-being
the sites of the proposed development is
used daily for activity by dog walkers
Runners horse riders Ramblers
so the show that's surrounding yourself
in nature either by exercise or by
sitting and watching nature relatively
impacts your mental and physical health
if the proposed development is approved
this is something that we as residents
of dark Lane and the surrounding areas
will lose
it's something that we benefit from and
utilize daily
if the proposed development meets
approval we residents will also have to
suffer the stress of additional laws and
traffic while construction is underway
and going forward from the additional
people living in such close proximity on
roads that are inadequately built to
carry the traffic
currently that they received 30 seconds
to emotional traffic
these are all issues that are affecting
the mental health of people on dark Lane
whilst we understand a need for
Development Across Northeast Derbyshire
this shouldn't be at the detriments of
people already in the area suffering
the proposed development
is inflicting stress
and causing mental health problems in a
time where it's difficult to move due to
ongoing environmental and economic
pressures please don't make us feel like
we need to leave our homes
thank you any questions
no thank you they'd like to take a seat
there's been a slight change to your
running order as we've got a couple of
people not here
so Mark Armstrong
three minutes when you're ready
I've lived on dark Lane for over 23
years
the disabled wheelchair needs 100
centimeters to maneuver safely on a
pavement a wheelchair plus one
pedestrian alongside needs 150
centimeters to maneuver the current
pavement on the top of Dart Lane is only
84 Centimeters therefore the width of
the current pavement will have to be
extended thus causing the dart Lane
Junction to be narrowed in even more
dangerous than it already is
the planet stays there are opportunities
to enhance the sensor place along Dart
Lane currently it is Arthur Street
and it is felt the proposals may act to
announce the sentence to enhance the
sense of it being a stream
our ridiculous dark Lane is Elaine not a
street and should remain as such
the proposed access
Point T Junction will itself become a
passing place where Vehicles driving
into it to avoid the traffic it will be
very dangerous
in the plans to propose houses across
the top edge of the field will be built
under the electricity cables pylons
by law you have to be 50 meters away or
it's a safety risk
I now quote the council's previous
reasons for refusing planning on the
same side nothing has changed since then
so therefore these points remain valid
the application is considered to be
unacceptable as the site is located
outside the settlement development limit
for Calo are set out in the council's
local plan
the loss of the Greenfield side will
have detrimental impact on the character
of the area and as an area of open
Countryside and its last is not
outweighed by the social and economic
benefits of the scheme
the application is considered to be
unacceptable as dark Lane is currently
poorly lit and instringently dark the
development would introduce Street and
other lighting that would adversely
affect the locally dark landscape and
the immunity of neighboring property of
occupiers
the development would access onto Dart
Lane where on route where on-road
parking is prevalent and off-road
parking is limited access to the main
Airway network is already restricted the
additional traffic arising from the
valley Duncans would have a detrimental
impact on the existing Highway Network
as Dart Lane is too narrow to
accommodate the additional traffic
and the access on top from the site to
Dart Lane and both North and South to
Top Road and Kayla Lane respected would
have adverse impact on our safety and
the cumulative impact and the
development would be severe please
reject this application
thank you any questions
no if you'd like to take a seat thank
you
and we were expecting someone by Zoom
but they don't appear to be around
so we will move on to the last speaker
the ejections and I do apologize if I
get your name wrong
Pietro
wonderful thank you if you'd like to
take a seat
three minutes when you're ready
good
my name is
resident of dark Lane
dark Lane is a single Track Road we pass
in place with agricultural land at
greenfields our examinated the plants
and I know they thought well a strongly
object to the proposed awesome
development of dark Lane object for the
Fallen prison The Proposal development
is situated in a Greenfield site
bordered by Edge roads rose trees and
strips of bucket ground this which
provided suitable for a variety of verbs
such as the black belt Bluetooth grated
long talented culted goldfing chuffings
tree and Edge sparrows with pigeon truth
and pheasant
soon of the less common birds are
sitting in around my neighborhood
include green prints colored of bull
Finch the Lesser spot woodpecker little
tiny house and Boozled we know that many
of these piece are at risk and and
decline
due to the environmental change and loss
of habitat the field is to land mass
including in the proposed development
side support many of the species have
mentioned
but the ground is spoken this provided
the right condition but in such a moral
of us to drive amphibians such as frogs
are also not to live in dumps of ground
if this land is developed it will take
away the habitat and the plantation
potential nature results that insects
small invertebrates provide in the
animal food chain butts Roost and forage
on the side and no refills to round my
neighborhood we know that all bats are
legally protected in Britain but what
will be hard to mitigate is the
reduction of the most enduring sets they
feed up if the develop development of
this Greenfield decide to go ahead this
break in the food chain will force them
to this place elsewhere filled mice
walls and shoes are also at risk from
this development
and are they are going to office
as well as the other birds these two
will destroy the habitat the Greenfield
fields and age roads are an important
natural result for this moss and
butterflies and the food they gathered
such as pulling a net we needed to
protect a preserve this unique
characteristic of dark Elaine for the
future of our children and grandchildren
thank you for listening
thank you are there any questions
no if you'd like to take your seat thank
you very much
okay and we're into our final group now
which is the agent Katrina Hughes
three minutes good can I just correct my
uh surname is Hulse
it's okay
good afternoon and thank you for giving
me this opportunity to speak in support
of the application the applicant
steinflip homes has worked proactively
with officers to achieve an acceptable
scheme the main change from the
originally submitted scheme is reduction
in the developable area of the site
reduction in the maximum number of
dwellings to be accommodated on the site
from 65 to 36 dwellings change from a
market housing scheme to 100 affordable
scheme although the site is located
outside the settlement development
limits of Calo a level two settlement
planning permission is sought for a 100
affordable scheme and policy lc3 allows
for proposals of this type provided they
meet the policy criteria the applicant
has provided detailed evidence to
Support Compliance with this policy we
are all aware of the significant and
urgent need for good quality affordable
homes across the country and the housing
assessment carried out to support this
application found over 30 applications
for every affordable home that became
available in the local Ward there is
undoubtedly a serious and substantial
shortfall of affordable homes in the
area
the council's housing strategy officer
agrees with this confirming a
demonstrual need for affordable housing
and therefore provision of a 100
affordable scheme should be given
significant weight in the determination
of this application
although there are local concerns in
respect to highway safety and ability to
safely access Top Road the highway
Authority has raised no concerns with
proposals at any point in the
application and does not object to the
application subject to the imposition of
conditions
the appellant has worked proactively
with the council and has amended the
scheme to limit built form in line with
conclusions from the lands council's
landscape consultant the landscape
impact of the scheme before use today is
considered acceptable by both the
applicant and the council's consultant
the large area in the west of the site
identified as Green Space will be
dedicated to biodiversity Improvement
and will enable a significant uplifting
biodiversity value which is a
substantial benefit of the scheme
Derbyshire Wildlife trusts support the
game to biodiversity the scheme offers
there are no technical objections to the
application proposal and detailed design
will take place at the reserve matter
stage this is a matter which the council
has control over 30 seconds remains
thereby ensuring that high quality
design is brought forward overall the
application proposal is a sustainable
form of development that complies with
local plan and mppf policies and will
deliver significant economic social and
environmental benefits it will make an
invaluable contribution to not only the
overall housing requirement but more
significantly to much needed affordable
housing I trust that you recognize the
benefits of the scheme and will be able
to support this development thank you
thank you are there any questions
counselor Elliot thank you chat
how many people off the dark Lane have
you spoken to about this application
um the the applicant sent round
um letters at various stages of the um
proposal
um setting up what we were planning to
do
we haven't had any sort of public
exhibition or sorry that's exactly what
I meant how many people have doorsteps
the people of dark Lane about this
application we have not just letters we
haven't knocked on on doors thank you
councilor Hall
yeah thank you I was just going to ask
when you talk about affordable housing
is it all for sale or will any be uh
going to like a Housing Association or
anything to rent please
[Music]
um
it will be managed by a registered
provider so it is is affordable housing
in as set out in the National planning
policy framework and and we're wanting
at least half of it to be for key worker
homes that would benefit you know local
people like Hospital workers
So when you say 100 affordable housing
100 to rent then is that correct
um well that's the the the exact mix of
affordable homes is to be determined but
they it has to be in complaint and that
will be done with your sort of housing
officer as to the exact mix of different
affordable Home Products
um available the the applicant is
committed to delivering affordable homes
for key workers okay thank you
councilor Foster thank you chair uh my
questions around uh the priority given
to NHS and key workers I've read that in
the documentation provided by our
officers but it's the first time I've
read unless I've missed it here that 50
will be targeted towards uh NHS and key
workers the first time I've heard about
50 so it will be a question I've got for
officers afterwards to see if that's
been provided uh but my question is
around what discount will they be given
I understand it's 30 that was uh put
forward by the government uh a couple of
years back by our government is that the
one you're referring to is that the
discount that will be given to NHS and
key workers uh and also how will that be
how will it be done how will you uh
provide that
so the delivery of the um you know the
affordable home scheme will be through a
registered sort of housing provider
um and and the sort of mechanism for for
delivering that will come at sort of a
later stage but obviously you know this
this schemes that's put forward the
application to skip description is for
affordable homes
um and it may be that
um you know when the applicant sits down
with register provider and the housing
strategy officer that a slightly
different mix of affordable homes types
you know are required at that stage it
will depend on on the need but you know
my my client is committed to sort of
delivering
um you know a good proportion of these
homes to key to key workers I mean if if
when when they do sit down that there
isn't maybe demand for 50 it depends or
that it might be more you know we don't
know at this stage but that that's their
commitment because they recognize that
you know with the hospital just down the
road and and nurses and and doctors and
other health workers
um needing sort of accommodations local
area that they're committed to sort of
providing that
yeah gonna come back uh yep uh but the
reason I'm asking that detail is because
one of the main things uh which we'll be
considering that we'll have to get
planning some uh some weight to this as
a as a material consideration it's how
much weight I should do when I come when
I make my decision so if there's not a
figure yeah and it's only something
that's up in the air at the minute and
no firm commitment of an actual
percentage other than this the first
time I've heard it and this this sort of
thing does happen from time to time and
you only Discover it while you're
actually here so I will be asking
officers afterwards what commitment we
have received up to now but if the
commitment as you've said it is 50 and
and we can and we can record that we
know where we're going and also I'll
repeat the other question which you
might have missed uh appreciate my
Mercedes what is the discount they'll be
given to key workers in NHS so it's the
actual discount it's 30 that's been
given by the state that was when the
scheme was launched and you know well if
I I'm not aware of the discount I mean
certainly with the um affordable Market
products it's 20 below market price that
that's I think in the definition of the
the mppf but if if if if the scheme for
key workers is 30 then
um you know that that is obviously you
know what what the uh um my sort of
client would sort of go along with but
all of this could be tied up in the
section 106.
but in terms of
um the commitment I'm not I'm not sure
about that it's quite important to this
very stage when it comes to whether we
think this should be uh you know we
should pass this and give it planning
permission I don't know if the uh I'd be
happy to hear from the chair that's
that's one of the main considerations I
would give it because it's mentioned in
there has been one of the reasons why we
should go against one of our policies
that is providing
um you know for NHS and key workers and
if it's not
and there's no discount being given or
it's just off the top of your head it
means I would give different you know
put different weights on it I think that
makes sense yeah
I'm quite happy if you want to clarify
that so we're all aware because this is
quite a key point
you may
click Holmes
um
the sources had difficult to explain
this because ultimately the Final Mix
will be determined a little bit closer
to the microphone please I'm sorry
um so how difficulty explaining this
because ultimately the Final Mix will be
determined by the registered social
landlord We Will We Will engage with
we'll call it a Housing Association for
general purposes but and they will
ultimately decide the mix that goes
forward some would be for rent some
would be for Discount uh market sales
um if there were discount market sales
something in the region of 25 to 30 is
what we would anticipate
um we see a prime purpose here to engage
with
um with essential workers because of the
proximity of the of the hospital sites
close to the hospital and therefore we
we would anticipate there will be
significant demand and therefore we
would want to Target those and therefore
a figure of 50 has been put forward
because it seems to me seems to us that
that's an appropriate mix
the final discount and the and the break
and the mix between
um discounted sales and and and
um and rent would ultimately be
determined by the uh Housing Association
but that we've given you there the scale
of where we would anticipate that that
should be I hope that's helpful
yeah it's helpful thank you
Yeah so basically I think that the
outcome of that is anything between 25
and 30 for the discount
yeah yeah no problem now okay are there
any more questions
thank you hello good afternoon hi I want
you to tell me you know when you say
affordable housing
can you put a key figure on that for a
property what would one property cost
because we have all this thing about
affordable housing what who are these
houses being targeted at yes we've heard
about the NHS and the people that work
there what we cook talk about affordable
housing and in very many areas people
say well we can't afford those houses
why are you letting them build
and I'm just wondering if we could so
the government policy and this is not
not me but government policy sets out
the definition of affordable
um affordable housing is not it
obviously it's their social
homes or social rent and that should be
a proportion of of what is delivered on
the site there's discounted Market
housing which is sort of typically sort
of 20 to 30 below the sort of the market
price there's also affordable Market
rent as well um rent as well which is a
similar discounted there's key worker
housing so that there is this sort of a
range of different types of affordable
housing product and and as the
applicants just said and I I was trying
to explain that the registered social
landlord it um housing provider will
determine what is required in this area
um so that the the right amount of the
different products are brought brought
forward
so it it's it's not as simple as it
perhaps was in the past where you had
just social rented housing
um yeah the the affordable home
provision the definition has expanded
and it is down to sort of um what is
needed in this this area and that's for
the affordable housing provider along
with the council's housing strategy
officer to determine the exact mix of
those affordable products does that
answer your
I asked you for a key figure I didn't
mean to figure out how many say rented
Properties or how many for sale if I if
we'll say off plot I call and I'll come
along and I want to buy one of your
properties the affordable housing to me
is how much how much is that house gonna
cost these aren't for Market sale though
they will all be every single one's
going to be rented that no not rented
you but the the the delivery of them and
and the that if they're going to be sort
of sale um sold a discount then that
will be sort of all agreed with them the
um I would really like to see the
outcome of that
because we we learn all the time about
different things that are happening with
the houses and I know where I come from
we have had loads of houses built and
they come in and say the affordable
housing we tell people their affordable
housing people then come back to us and
say well actually no they're not
affordable to us we can't afford those
and that's what I'm saying
you know maybe I haven't come across the
way I wanted to but it's all about the
money
to me
you know I'd probably come along and I
would probably be able to afford one of
those houses never in a million years
and I know that from the the houses that
have gone around where I personally live
what are supposed to be affordable so
whether discounted or not there's got to
be some making of the money of course to
the Builder
so you know you know it's not going to
be given away all the figures are going
to be factored in
I mean I I
that that's why as part of the mix there
will be social rented housing but it's
obviously got to be it there's got to be
the proportion of that social rented
housing's got to be in line with what's
required in in that particular area and
that that's the advice that will come
from you know the housing um strategy
officer and it will be sort of delivered
through the registered housing provider
that one okay
are there any further questions
no thank you if you'd like to take a
scene
I do um have a an option for the people
the objectives to our skill set in the
room if you want to stay in the room you
can or you can join your colleagues in
the waiting room
thank you
thank you
before we go into the debate a short
Comfort break five minutes
let's go I'm going to say a couple of
people are disappearing
I could have suggest to members the
facilities that ends as opposed to that
end
questions to our planning officers
cancer Armitage counselor Foster
counciloria in that order please
right
are we ready
uh how many houses
who's got one on
no how many hours were the original uh
other in the planning uh stage at the
moment for Caleb
with all the various ones that have been
us
uh answer Armitage is not really
relevant at this stage we're listening
to the this application
it's not relevant to this application
34.
they've already undescribed for 65.
oh hello
thank you chair a question for officers
what two questions first one is a
uh fairly simple one I'm sure we heard
uh the chap coming from the Royal
Hospital uh asking us to object
um
and refuse this planning application so
it's a it's just advice from planning
officers should we be taking this into
account because it's the first time I've
come across this uh from a from a
hospital where the where they'd actually
send a REV to say uh you know to object
so do we give it weight that that's the
first question thank you chair
be
106 requirements of the scheme was set
out in the report as members will have
read in terms of these specific requests
from the Royal Hospital
our consideration of that is that the
evidence hasn't been provided that
provides that definitive support for the
scheme and so in officer's opinion it
doesn't meet the sale tests and so we've
not included in our consideration of the
106 requests
just overall in terms of the 106
contribution requested all the other
requests have been agreed with the
applicant doesn't that sold one from the
Royal Hospital
hopefully that that answers the question
yeah uh thanks it's just unusual that's
all in the way it was brought across you
know anyway
um the other question uh when it comes
to the same questions we put to the uh
that I put to the agent regarding
um affordable housing the 100 the 50
uh targeted at Key workers NHS workers
uh what do you I know we've said it's uh
that's going to be forwarded on a later
stage but at this stage uh it's all good
uh hopefully receiving that but to make
a decision at this stage can I ask what
uh you've got in addition to what's
mentioned in the pike which I've read
what what else do you have anything
about the 50 do you have anything about
the discount that may be offered do you
have anything as well as officers that
we can consider and give a give weight
to thank you chair
I'll come back initially and then if
Graham's got to the elements he wants to
add um just in in terms of the the
application as Caster Foster says it's
for 100 affordable housing as a totality
and in terms of the assessment against
your policy lc3 it would be relevant to
the consideration of that policy and how
much weight you can give to that policy
will be for yourselves well as officers
we've given that
I think in the in the we've said
considerable weight so we we put a lot
of weight on that 100 affordable housing
the applicant is also set out within his
submissions that there will be this 50
percent
set aside for key workers NHS workers
now in terms of an officer assessment we
don't think that tips the balance in
terms of consideration policy because as
100 affordable housing it would in our
opinion meet the terms of your policy
else you want to stand alone however if
you as members wish to place weight on
that in your consideration you would
need to then include that in any
decision that you've taken so if you're
placing weight on that 100 but with 50
of that is it for key workers or
particularly for NHS workers Hospital
workers you would need to specify that
we would then need to include that in I
would suggest a 106 agreement so then
that would have to find some mechanism
of of meeting that need from within that
pool
so I hope I've explained that well if
offices aren't
putting weight on that NHS pool but if
members are and that tips the balance
for you in favor of granting Bishop
risking you'd need to find a mechanism
for including that in any decision in
terms of the discount the mppf is clear
that the discount across all the
affordable housing ranges is 20 so you
take the market rate discount 20 and I
can't help Council arouse in terms of
what that market rate is but that would
be something that would be generally
assessed by by surveyors or professional
as to what the market rate is and then
you discount 20 of that and that's
included in your your pack the issue of
30 is I believe referenced to the
um I hope I've got the terminology right
here but the starter homes uh you know
first homes that is the scheme that's
relatively recently been set up by
government which is for first first
homes but then there's that element for
this element of that that are weighted
for key workers and and that document
talks about 30 percent
so again if that was an important
consideration for you we would need to
make that
um assessment although we're getting a
number of
schemes submitted to us whereby the
start the the first homes is an
additional element to the otherwise 20
affordable housing that we would
normally require as part of residential
schemes
so I hope that's that's right and I've
explained it sufficiently well
thank you for that thank you Jim Council
Elliot
thank you chair Adrian can you tell me
how you came to a decision of something
like this outside the settlement
development limits
and because I know not a lot of people
sat around this table was sat here in
2015 when I was it may even be me but
threw it out
uh and and that was for me nothing
nothing at all has changed you've still
got the issue with well I'll let you
answer the other question first Adrian
and then I'll rant later
the situation back in
um it was certainly pre-2019 I can't
remember the exact date when we previous
application was submitted and determined
um so the situation was different then
you had um an out-of-date local plan
there was the five-year housing land
Supply issue that was considered then in
terms of the current application you now
have an adopted local plan and you
should first of all take decisions in
accordance with that local fund unless
material matters
lead you to a different conclusion and
officers note the issue that cancer
Armitage alluded to earlier on that the
site lies outside the settlement
development limits but the way that your
plan is written in an officer opinion is
that's not the end of the story and you
need to take a balanced approach across
the development plan as a whole you
shouldn't just cherry pick one Ellen
Toby can put or necessarily excessive
weight on that one element you need to
balance all the elements and come to a
conclusion as to acceptability of the
scheme as a whole in accordance with the
development plan and in this instance in
officer opinion and for example policy
ss1 talks about settlement limits but it
also talks about protection and hunting
the quality of the settings of towns and
Villages the landscape
placing development in sustainable
locations where there's good access to
Services jobs transport links Etc so in
terms of policy ss1 officers has taken
that balanced view across those various
strands
the policy SS2 then talks about where
General development will be directed to
and that talks about directing housing
provision to level two settlements which
is where where Kayla is and also in
terms of policy ss9 which is your
Countryside protection policies that is
a positive policy which says within
Countryside areas development will be
given permission if it meets a number of
criteria this doesn't but it doesn't
then exclude other development so that's
the starting point for the opposite
conclusion we then balance those
policies or taken into account the
advice we've been given in terms of
landscape harm and an office of you is
that on the balance of those policies
I'll come to affordable housing in a
second if I may be on the balance of
those policies
the scheme in its reduced form is
acceptable
we've then as officers added weight to
that in terms of the 100 affordable
housing that is being offered and you
may argue alone that meets your policy
lc3 and would allow you to grab
permission taking your balance approach
so I hope that that explains the officer
approached the scheme and our conclusion
weighing all the advice that we received
from landscape advisors and policy
colleagues and others
thanks chair can I just ask Adrian and
Adrian I I'm quite happy that I I've
taken a balanced approach to it and I
haven't cherry-picked one item and like
you said you know you Cherry Picked the
100 affordable to to help with your
balance of the situation and I I look at
ss1 and I don't think that and that that
enhances any local distinctiveness
and and and for me you know
the ss9 part of it supporting new
housing in in in
that part of the countryside don't wash
for me either because nothing really for
me has changed from the last application
and I and I could take my balance view
if you wanted me to carry on further
with the drainage the accidents on dark
line the fact that it is actually on
that lane where where the parking is
people need to have a drive down there
of an evening when the residents of top
Road and dart Lane will call it what you
mean cannot park outside their own
properties because there is no parking
and they Park in yards and yards and
yards away
and and really some you know it's it's
such a narrow place to try and get
through and there are only passing
places and on the stretch where Dart
Lane is there are no passing places it
purely is a single Track Road
so I I have taken a balanced approach
and I've worked and driven down that
thing all my life so you know I like
some of the locals who were speaking
earlier and I've got shed loads that
I've written on every person who's
spoken today
and and I just I just can't support it
but thank you very much for your answer
yeah Chad just just briefly I can just
come back to cash Early Times hopefully
I've explained the officer approach to
to our conclusion it's for you as a
collector who's planning committees to
whether you agree with that or whether
you put weight on other elements and
that that is your planning judgment and
your planning expertise which you need
to bring to to um to the assessment just
in terms of the technical elements happy
to to discuss those with you but as far
as officers are concerned and the
evidence that we believe is before you
there doesn't appear to be any technical
reason why the scheme isn't acceptable
and as I often have the discussion with
with members at planning committee in
listening to what's been said to you
this afternoon you need to be sure that
that translates to evidence that
outweighs the evidence that he's in
support of the scheme so you've heard a
lot this afternoon about oh it says
she's parking and traffic on Top Road
Etc but I'd I'd ask you to be wary of
the weight you put on those aspects and
you must be happy that you have or can
translate that into justifiable evidence
tangible evidence that you can bring to
bear should this or a technical reason
to refuse the application be tested at
appeal
thank you Adrian
any other questions
uh councilor Foster then councilor
Cooper uh thank you chair uh I just like
uh officers to just uh cover some doubts
I've got about
um which which is what I see development
in the countryside
and uh that and around policy at LC
three we've got uh lc3 there's
um I've got my doubts in here as an
individual uh planning a member about
whether these are all met but in
particular uh 1D so what I'm looking for
is is some some confidence from officers
that this has actually been met on the
surface of it it doesn't feel like it
like it has been so if we read lc3 1D
uh it speaks later on in 1D are in
keeping with the form size and character
of the settlement and local landscape
setting well my view of everything I've
seen is it clearly doesn't do that to me
in in my eyes but I've just wonder how
officers could if you could uh give me
some confidence that you feel that when
you consider this and giving a plan you
know weight and planning consideration
do you feel and obviously you must do
but I'm just wanting you to explore that
a little bit more that 1D has actually
been met so it is in keeping with the
form size and collector of the
settlement because
lc3 it must meet all those criteria not
one of them it must be one to e it must
meet the whole lot for us to override
ss9 in development in the countryside so
that's my concern chair if that makes
sense to officers thank you
um as cancer Foster's Lewy too yes we do
as I guess we wouldn't have recommend it
positively on the scheme but in terms of
that that issue the site does then have
a close Association in our opinion with
a class level two settlement in that it
is bound on two sides by the the
settlement development limit
in terms of the impact on the the local
landscape setting characters the
settlement all those elements we've
sought advice from
um landscape Consultants on that and and
we've taken their view into account and
in particular it's the constrained
nature of the
housing that's now Falls part of the
application that is played in our minds
in that on the Northwestern Northeastern
side there is existing housing so
there's the developed opposite Calo
Church on the Northwestern side on the
northeastern side was the development
the other side of Dart Lane itself and
then on the south eastern Corner because
I think that's probably called the
homestead so our view is that Society is
constrained within those built built
reforms and therefore doesn't
leak out into the countryside from that
General built form and again that's the
basis of our consideration
Council Cooper
thank you chair I'm not quite sure
um that this is relevant but I'm not
sure how relevant at this time but
um Adrian you just said you've you've
obviously put a lot of weight and
control your weight on the 100 of all
the loans
my question
um is how achievable is 100 affordable
homes
with only 36 properties
and what kind of quality and design
would that mean and the reason for the
question is
we hear very often uh 100 or a certain
percent of affordable homes is difficult
to achieve and I'm concerned and the
this if it's passed today it will just
stand there with no development as an
outline
the offer of it being 100 Ford pricing
has come from the developer so that's
something that's offered to us and as
we've set out in the report we've given
that considerable weight in view of the
the council's affordable housing
provision and the identified need for
affordable housing across the history
not necessarily in caliberate across the
district
the
if you were to Grant permission for the
for the scheme this afternoon you could
control the requirement 400 affordable
housing through I would suggest probably
a 106 agreement is the best way of doing
that and then if the applicant decided
for whatever reason 100 affordable
housing couldn't or wasn't going to be
provided you would need to come back to
the council seeking to to vary that
agreement and if it were contained
within 106 agreement there will be no
compulsion on the council to agree to
that within five years of the agreement
being signed and after that formal
application would need to be made in any
case to alter the agreement I can't
however say to you that the scheme if it
were granted permission would be
developed out but there would be a
requirement to start it within the three
years as as normal unless you felt an
earlier time was important in view of
the the issues that you just raised so
if you felt it was important it was
delivered before three years the normal
period you would need to specify that
and give reason why
in terms of the design and quality that
would be controlled normally through the
reserve any reserve matters application
so you would retain control over that
any further questions
Council Armitage do you want to go
through
okay fine that's that's you know at
least 10 minutes of overtime
right I shall open the floor for debate
then counselor Liggett
um basically the new head of Highways
the first thing I wrote down that he
said was um the way we're looking at
things is changing uh we need to think
about queuing traffic
and carbon reduction
and to prioritize pedestrian cyclists
and horses
then Mr Wells I think it was Mr Wells
brought up the air pollution issue
they said the Royal College of London
had been out and um that Junction was in
the Amber region
which I found quite horrifying really
that
you know I think that's very relevant
now if if we're going to look at things
in a different way
and everybody well practically everybody
that's been in I've mentioned queuing
traffic and traffic overload Etc I think
it's something that should be considered
any other comments
Elston Hancock
thanks chair I mean I agree with cancer
Ali it costs I'm quite used to that road
and you go down there at night and you
cannot pass and that's eyewitness
evidence so it doesn't really get any
better than that when it comes to
challenging well highways have sat as a
desk have done
um it again it concerns me because
largely even though we've got a lot of
paperwork here and we've had a lot of
witnesses we're looking purely at this
access route
and the fact that we haven't got huge
amounts of information in terms of
what's happening and it's good that
we're looking at a potential affordable
housing for key workers but key workers
as one of those speakers said are going
to have a disproportionate impact on the
number of traffic Because by the nature
of their job they they can't work from
home they're two in and from him which
if it was open to General Public
that that would actually counterbalance
some of it
um so I don't feel
comfortable that we've got enough of how
where this application is going to make
a proper decision today
um based on that there's too many
intangibles that could be you might be
let's bring you back to reserve matter
as well we're wanting the decision today
and I don't feel that we can comfortably
make one that would find in its favor
there's nothing here that would say we
should reach our own policies because
we've got nothing to actually evidence
why we should
um so unfortunately that's where I stand
with it
I'm going to throw my two pillars in and
really upset everybody
I quite like this um development it's
small development it's not very often
we're offered 100 affordable housing and
are no affordable
Is An Open Bracket
I know the standard of workmanship and
build quality has been raised
not personally knowing
um anyone relating to Stan Cliff homes
but we have had staying close
development within wingerworth their
build quality and layout is superb
and I have no issue regarding that
development and the quality that they
would deliver
I am struggling I'm struggling with the
access onto this road I don't often use
it I did it the other day and I've
chosen to use it at different times
I do count take counselor leggett's time
about queuing unfortunately we queue
everywhere because of the traffic that
is everywhere man does not want to give
up his car I am one of them because it's
easier to use we can't rely on public
transport
so
hand on heart I'm going to have to
support this application and I know
there's many around this table that
probably disagree with me wholeheartedly
but that's my two pennies
Adrian said
Jesus
Adrian said about they'd taken a lot of
advice from the landscapers and so on
and so forth
I'm taking a lot of cognizance of the 19
people who've been unspoken
and not one of them repeated themselves
every single one brought in a different
reason they all lived there they've
brought in a different reason why we
should turn it down I personally see no
difference yes the local plans change
and we've now got a local plan and you
know there are a couple of policies that
I'll happily quote but and I look at
that with the people who live there and
I can't hand on Art sit there and say
that development's in the right place
at all
and I'm not going to put my name to it
so that's that's my uh that's my
feelings over thank you any other
comment
answer Amity
you mentioned uh the quality of the
build and all the rest of it you're
probably looking at open market houses
this uh
there won't be much profit uh I mean
we've had this before on uh affordable
houses
and time and time again people have come
and said oh yes we're going to do so
many affordable housing we all think oh
great there'll be some affordable houses
well it doesn't work like that because
it got to be profit at the end of the
day
and
they've come back time and time again so
oh well we can't deliver it uh instead
of 20 we can only do five percent or ten
percent you know and we've already given
permission and it's wrong and here we
are we've already turned this uh well an
application down previously and I can't
see there's any difference to this than
the other you're going to lose a
Greenfield site outside the settlement
development limit I mean what is the
point in having these settlement
development limits if we're not going to
adhere to them and I'm sorry I can't
support this application
against Japan
uh thank you chair actually I can
support it
um
as far as the Witnesses were concerned I
think
interesting what cancer Elliott said and
I would only say that Recollections may
vary
um because I heard the same thing over
and over again and they were throwing
the kitchen sink at it to be honest
um coming up with anything at all which
had no relevance in terms of planning
policy
um or the nnpf
um I think it was summed up for me by
one of the witnesses who said residents
like it the way it is well if we were on
to take that attitude everything would
just die wouldn't it and wither
um so I think this is a tremendous
opportunity to have affordable homes
some of the key workers if necessary at
a time to be um to be decided so I fully
support it thank you chap
thank you chair uh while we're in debate
uh I'll mention what my concerns are my
concerns are much like people who will
will gather from earlier with my
questions to officers they're still
around ss9 and this is where we've got
to uh what we got to consider as a as a
committee it's where we put weight on
these separate uh material
considerations and now we put them uh
how we address them to our policies so
when we look at ss9 development in the
in the countryside uh it goes against
that policy but because it's affordable
I still don't feel that the policies of
lc3 conditions are met now all of those
conditions have to be met and when you
look through them and re-read them
they're clearly not all met that's a
that's how I understand it and that's
how I see that so uh that's ss9 and lc3
my other concern is around SDC 3 which
is landscape character and in particular
the the first part of stc3 which is
proposals for new development will only
be permitted where they would not cause
significant harm to the character
quality distinctiveness or sensitivity
of the landscape and for that this this
clearly does it's it's development in
our Countryside outside the settlement
limit I can see the value that people
may put on uh affordable units
absolutely and I can see some people
will will put that consideration and say
it's enough to development to develop in
the countryside my own view is that it's
not Countryside to Countryside it's
outside a settlement limit and it
breaches both those
um both sdc3 and ss9 I can see other
people's concern around uh the traffic
and uh the Junctions we've been here
before uh there's not enough there for
me to oppose it on uh when it comes to
traffic it doesn't meet the criteria uh
for me that's I understand it which is
why I'm not willing to
um consider voting and turning down this
application on anything to do with
traffic that's how I feel about it but I
feel solely ss9 and sdc3 uh and lc3
that's that's where I feel uh my
concerns are around
thank you chair
okay
thank you uh I'm in two minds with this
application I've got to say to be honest
um I do think it's outside the
settlement area
um there's no real guarantee on
affordable housing
um and the the one little element it's
not I know we need affordable housing
but it's not in the high value area
where we need
affordable housing
it's a it
um Halo doesn't come into that area so
I'm I'm struggling with it uh I think
there's a few too many if some books
with it
um
from the highways I was gonna look at it
from a Highway's point of view earlier
but from what we've had earlier it's
clear that on highways there's no we've
got no crime on it at all
um so yeah I'm struggling with a
decision if I'm honest I'm very 50 50
whether it should go through or not
thank you thank you any other comment
no no further questions
so we come to motions
so that will explain
yes thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that Amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
than the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion is to if a motion to reject
officer recommendations falls on other
words it is not passed that doesn't mean
that the recommendations are
automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion and
favor the recommendations or a different
course of action
this will be needed to be this will need
to be approved by the committee through
another vote thank you chair
thank you
so emotion I'm going to throw this on
the table and I think I know which way
it'll go and that is to go with the
officer's recommendation
so we're ready for a roll call
yeah
so the motion is to approve officer
recommendations
councilor Armitage against
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Foster against
councilor Hall
against
councilor Hancock against
councilor Hartson
or
counselor leg is against
councilor Jones oh
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse for
councilor Ruff or
that's five for the votes and for the
motion and seven against the motionist
volunteer okay it Applause for another
motion counselor earlier Chad I'm going
against officer recommendation
I think it's contrary to policies ss9
development in the countryside I don't
think lc3 outweighs that I think it's
also contrary to sdc3 the landscape
character would have been outside the
settlement development limit as well
thank you
and I have a second councilor Foster
check news before we take the vote can I
just come in and ask a clarification
question please of council if I meant
um is the issue Council just one of
landscape impact and therefore one
reason of refusal which all three
policies would feed into in terms of
scale sighting location and impact on
the quality of the landscape is Council
Foss said or is it
two two reasons if you like that and an
issue of affordable housing
sorry I think the affordable comes into
it but particularly sdt3 uh one is is
the name on an ss9 ss9 and the sdc3 are
for me the main points in the affordable
obviously plays into it as well with
with no enough information on that yeah
accounts the Foster did talk about I
think the the issue of our LC battery
um Dean which which talks about local
landscape setting I'm just wanting to to
clarify it's that one reason in terms of
of landscape and we can make reference
to all three policies in that respect
rather than anything else to do with
affordable housing
uh agent yeah thanks for that you're
saying STC three one two and three yeah
I think which is a counselor Elliot's
mentioned for me my concerns are around
one
um
is that is that that the part you mean I
think I may have and quotely threatening
I was and just make benefits to policy
lc3
D's l1d
yeah
um that talks about local landscape
setting so I'm just trying to clarify
that it's it's one reason which is in
terms of the impact on the landscape
rather than an issue about afford allows
you just want to get it right so we
could have one
recent refusal it talks about that
landscape impact and we can reference
all three policies
if I can just have a second share
because it's uh I'm second in the motion
uh so I'm just going to read this
um one moment certainly D which is what
I mentioned
this is just getting clarification that
um if I'm right cancer your concern is
regarding scale form design impact in
terms of policy ss9 to
sdc3 which is related to landscape only
and then counter Foster's discussion
that we had was about obviously lc31
on that chair through the chair
um when they're you see I'd be happy to
include others uh for example like it
can be demonstrated that there are no
suitable alternative development
locations within the settlement
development layer now I'd feel that way
to include that but it may be that
officers have received that uh
demonstration I've not received it and
I'm not seen in the paperwork so I feel
uncomfortable about putting that in uh
because it may be the offices are being
satisfied that that's being met now I
haven't but you may well have so that's
why I'm having a bit of difficulty with
that and similarly with 1e it can be
demonstrated that the properties will be
allocated to those in local housing need
now it they might have uh demonstrated
it to yourself but I don't feel
satisfied that it's been demonstrated to
me and because of that I don't feel like
I don't feel like second in uh to
include it because I don't feel because
any decision we make here and put
forward that if we do turn this down and
refuse uh permission it's got to stand
up and uh and it's got to be a
defensible so I'm aware of I'm aware of
that so that's my concerns not to
include more than D does that make sense
Adrian and and just in terms of that
through you chair and officers have set
out in the papers about
um other alternative development sites
within Calo and we we have set out we're
satisfied there aren't any of those
right but I I think that
um if you're concerned about old
clc31e you could control that through
your 106 or conditions like and I would
not include it so we'll be perfectly in
fact it would just be one one reason
which relates to the landscape impact
the setting of the settlement Etc yeah
are we are we all happy with that now
okay over for a roll call okay sorry
just to be clear then and the focus is
here uh on the fact that the development
would be in the countryside and its
impact on the landscape in particular
also those issues about the scale and
the design of the development
that the essence of it members
okay on that basis uh
uh councilor you looked a bit concerned
I'm just confirmed that you were happy
with that
[Music]
policy or not and already written down
the change
uh both really
demonstrated
okay thank you if I can just stand here
maybe um the the reason refusal can be
delegated himself in consultation with
yourself
so we can make sure we get and
encapsulate the um
councilor Armitage for
councilor Cooper
counselor alias
councilor Foster or
councilor hall for
councilor Hancock for
counselor Hartzell against
councilor Leggett for
councilor Jones
councilor Powell
counselor Rouse against
and councilor Roth against
so I make it eight four and four against
the motionless pasture
thank you thank you all very much
for the Long Haul okay there's only one
out and if you want to leave you may
your
okay
switching off moving to the last part
the agenda today which is the Appeals
are there any questions on the Appeals
and just just raise 1.2 members and
second but if any members do ask you at
the moment we're now sending out repeal
decisions to all members to avoid any
change in um the membership so if any
members ask you why they're receiving
appeals not in your ward or not related
to anything that they can think of in
particular it's because we're sending
them to all so we catch everybody so
hopefully that's working out yeah but I
would um as always suggest that members
who have a look at the three appeal
decisions because they do raise some
very interesting issues particularly the
two in that have been dismissed which
relate to the conversion of a building
and extensions to buildings in the green
belt so they they do offer some good
pointers to how we determine
applications thank you chair
thank you and thank you to all for today
I know some of you have been here since
uh 12 o'clock so thank you for your time
and see you at full Council
safe journey home